the people with an axe to grind in 2020
it can be anyone players coaches gm's
owners anybody anyway anyhow chris give
me the trivia question and if i get it
right i get the first pick
okay here we go all right uh oops wait
i'm lost here i lost my spot here hold
on one second here we go i got that
that's fine
okay here we go sorry here we go cam
newton the first he's the first number
one overall pick
to be cut by the team that drafted him
since whom
okay
i repeat
who was the last number one pick
to be cut
by the team that drafted them
wow cut by the team that drafted them i
i
i can't think of anybody other than
jamarcus russell
good job big guy or am i wrong you are
right
i thought it was a trick question
um 2011 and now all right jamarcus
russell see you later and first one for
me look it's easy to say cam newton but
i cam newton is going to make it clear
to us publicly that he's got an axe to
grind
a guy who is i'm not taking cam newton
take it off the thing i'm taking tom
brady as my pick because
he
he's never going to say it
he's never going to acknowledge it but
that fire is going to burn inside of him
because at the end of the day he's going
to convince himself the patriots didn't
want him and the patriots are going to
try to sell the idea that tom wanted to
leave but the bottom of it all he
believed that bill didn't want him and i
think he is going to be motivated and
he's going to be determined and he's
going to do everything in his power to
show that they screwed up by letting him
walk away
yeah i i don't disagree with you there i
mean yes he's it's it's the way any nfl
competitor
kind of is wired in their brain you're
going to fool yourself to being oh i
feel disrespected and he has a right to
feel that way i mean come on he's one of
the greatest players of all time if not
the greatest certainly the most
decorated and i'm sure he is going to
feel a little bit cheated by the new
england patriots to a degree but i'm
with you he's going to be motivated this
year to show everybody you know it
wasn't belichick i'm still really good
screw you and i got two good years left
in me so i'm with you not a bad pick
there i mean i gotta go with cam newton
i think that's just the obvious one you
know it is i mean cam newton has about
as much of a right to be pissed off as
anybody in football right now you know
one hey he's getting disrespected as a
professional right just because of you
know yeah injury history and all that
who's gonna sign them we don't know
carolina didn't want him but i mean i
think you got a like an extra axe to
grind
when
you know the carolina panthers and in my
opinion kind of did them dirty and let
them go with the you know at the the
midnight hour to basically say oh yeah
go try to find a trade or find somebody
else where all the seats have already
been filled so that to me is going to
motivate cam newton let alone i think he
was motivated already because he's been
injured the last two years and hasn't
been able to show you know what kind of
player he really is capable of being
i i think you're you're absolutely right
and he i think he's going to be great
wherever he lands and it's amazing to me
that there has no and i understand that
the covet 19 situation makes it
impossible to to give the guy a physical
but the fact we've heard nothing and the
fact that there's no sense of anybody
that's going to make a move on him when
they have a chance to do it surely there
are teams that are looking at cam newton
looking at the other options and
realizing holy crap cam newton's our guy
and we talked about this earlier
the the message from colin coward
yesterday this take that call that cam
newton and tyrod taylor are basically
the same guy i think that's coming
straight from the chargers to colin
coward and it tells me the chargers have
decided not to make a move for cam
newton and to and to leave it with tyra
taylor unless they are trying to
leverage cam newton to reduce his
financial expectations but that that's
not coward's idea that was planted to
him i believe by the chargers and it's
very telling as to where the charges are
and if the charges aren't in on cam
newton i don't know who's going to be
but i think plenty teams should be all
right next one for me now there's a
difference between having an axe to
grind and actually being able to swing
the axe once you've ground the axe and
that's derek carr cause i i think he's
destined to no longer be the raiders
quarterback by next year it looks like
he's still going to get one more chance
this year but after all the tom brady
talk that for a while was kind of real
and bringing in marcus mariota to
potentially be the ryan tannehill to
mariota that mariota could be this year
to derek carr and and be the guy that
the raiders can turn to if carr would
need to be benched and now he's going to
have to sweat out whether or not the
raider's going to draft somebody they're
reportedly talking to justin herbert so
uh you know carr
uh a little thin-skinned anyway but i
think he's got multiple reasons to be
upset and to get himself focused and to
try to turn it into a positive and i i
assume this is the psychology of john
gruden chris he wants to do that he
wants to make him mad he wants to push
his buttons and he hopes that that
results in a higher level of performance
from derek carr this year
yeah and then no doubt about it i mean
one he wants competition at the position
he does i don't think he cares who you
are two yes he wants you to feel that
hey there's a hot poker really close to
my butt here and i i gotta keep going
and pushing forward or i'm gonna have a
big red mark on my butt all right so yes
he is that way let alone you know if you
do get hurt or aren't playing well he
wants to have options to as i always
used to tell you you know he looks at
his offense as a real
awesome red ferrari and he doesn't want
to give the keys to that red ferrari to
anybody so yes if the starter gets hurt
he wants to have somebody he can trust
to be in the back up too and yeah derek
carr is going to have to sweat it out
because if gordon does like justin
herbert i wouldn't put it past them to
to draft the guy like that i certainly
wouldn't um
all right man there's a lot of options
to pick here um
i'm gonna go with melvin gordon of the
denver broncos all right melvin gordon
you know i look at him and just go man
you know yes does he have an axe to
grind one he's got a probably a little
bit of an axe to grind with himself he's
probably kicking himself a little bit
going man i left money on the table with
the los angeles chargers and look i
signed for less the next year so he's
probably pissed off about that he's
going to want to show the world that he
is worth big time running back money he
stayed in the division so he's going to
get to see the chargers twice a year and
i think he's going to want to show them
and then shove it up where the sun don't
shine to them to say hey look you know
i'm the bell cow running back for you
know the denver broncos here and having
a great year and and you guys should
assign me back so i look at all those
factors and look at melvin gordon as a
guy to be extra motivated let alone and
a chance to succeed pat shurmur likes to
run the football i like his run game
design and you know i think mike munchek
is one of the best offensive line
coaches in all of football and fangio's
going to want to run the ball so i look
for melvin gordon to have a big year and
to shut up a lot of the haters of the
world
i was so hoping that you were going to
say that melvin gordon is going to
self-grind himself i thought that was
coming
but you're right he's he's his own worst
enemy here he admitted in his
introductory conference call with the
broncos that he probably shouldn't have
held out into the regular season he
skipped four games he got nothing out of
it i remember when we interviewed him at
the super bowl one of his handlers was
giving me a little attitude afterward oh
did you tell him uh what a mistake his
holdout was i said no he knows
he knows he's very real with himself but
yeah yeah that's what i like about the
guy i've been around melvin a few times
he's very honest open he's not he's in
reality uh and yeah he's oh you know
he's he's cool that way he really is i
root for him he's one of those humans
you meet in football where you just go
that's a good guy i see the talent he's
built like a greek god he's had some
injury issues he went for it yeah he's
worried he's plays running back he gets
killed for a living i mean he gets
crushed so he wanted to maximize what he
could do i'm not going to be mad at him
for that but at the same time it cost
him a few dollars
next one for me is another running back
who played in the same city as melvin
gordon and that's todd gurley and look i
mean todd gurley on one hand you can
look at it and say
he really doesn't have an axe to grind
because this is the reality of having a
knee injury from college that didn't
dramatically impact his draft stock he
was still the 10th overall pick in 2015
and after a few years of playing at a
high level and being the
nfl's offensive player of the year in
2017
the knee just couldn't hold up anymore
and he's done everything he can and he's
fought and he's worked and it just got
to the point where his contract no
longer is justifiable based upon his
current health but here's where he has
an axe to grind and this struck me as
very unusual chris when he admitted to
chris long last week on long's podcast
that gurley didn't see his release by
the rams coming my first thought was
he's he's lying to us surely he saw it
coming peter king and i talked about
this on friday and i assume you you
weren't up and watching the show then i
saw some of it
yeah peter made a great point
the point is that with a guy like sean
mcveigh as your coach maybe you don't
see it coming because maybe sean mcvay's
got that pete carroll
raw raw everything is great everything
is positive you're my guy you're my guy
until you're no longer his guy and then
it does hit you like a bag full of
bricks upside the head when he finally
tells you you're gone and if that's how
it went down if it's a little at john
gruden right you're my guy until you're
not my guy anymore and and who was one
of his mentors it was john gruden and i
think that that gurley may come out of
this experience pissed off about being
led to believe he was still part of the
rams plans being led to believe he's
still sean mcvay's guy being led to
believe that they're still going to
build an offense around him and then all
of a sudden he gets wadded up into a
ball and thrown in the trash that's
going to give him an extra grind with
the falcons in 2020.
yeah i mean i agreed on all points now
you know he can take some solace in the
fact that hey he was paid very
handsomely and they took a chance on him
they took a chance on him not only in
the draft right but also by giving him
the the contract extension you know he
was a guy that came out in the draft of
the torn acl and they drafted him in the
top 10. so you know i think you got to
take that into account too and to your
point about sean mcvay i think that's
very real you know i think a little bit
like mcveigh and gruden yeah there's the
good cop bad cop aspect between the gm
and the head coach the head coach needs
to stay in favor with the players and
you know you know sean mcvay i know sean
mcvay he's one of those guys he just he
doesn't he's not a fake to me i think he
really loves his players he wanted i'm
sure he was like man can't we keep todd
gurley to the last very minute he was
probably hoping that could work out
which is yes probably blindsided todd
gurley to a degree i'm sure they've
talked since then but yeah i'm with you
i mean todd girl is going to be
motivated and pissed off and want to
show everybody that he's still one of
the better running backs in football all
right
the the the deal is still not official
in atlanta they could try to take him
back the way they took back michael
brocker so who knows maybe that story's
not over yet yeah i know i mean yeah i
think there could be a few stories like
that in the nfl all right i'm gonna stay
with the rams and one that i bet you
wasn't on your radar but should it be
jaylen ramsey you had him on there no it
wasn't no
oh jaylen ramsey to me
he's got each you got an axe to grind
first off jalen ramsey's you know been
arguably not arguably forget arguably
he's been one of the three best corners
in football the last three years in the
nfl you know whether you want to say
he's one two or three whatever i don't
care all i know is he's one of the best
cover corners and best corners in all
the football and he's sitting there and
he's played he's done it the right way
he's been a team guy he hasn't been
disgruntled but still
no long-term contract offer for jalen
ramsey
the best at his position in the whole
sport he's got to be looking at the free
agency this year going what
but byron jones is making 16 and a half
million a year you know he's probably
looking at darius slay james bradberry
and no disrespect to any of those guys i
think they're phenomenal players but
jalen ramsey's looking at them going
i've been better i am better and why
can't i get a long-term contract and
somebody pay me already so i look at
jalen ramsey as one of those guys that's
going to be pissed off he's pissed off
anyways when he's walking on the field
but he'll have an extra edge to him to
prove to everybody that he deserves to
be the highest paid cornerback in
football and i think you know that
happens whether it happens during the
season or after the season it's gonna
happen
he's making 13.7 million this year in
his fifth year option because he was a
top 10 pick right but look he's just
like we talked about laramie tunzel
earlier on the tv side yeah having
leverage over the texans because of what
they gave up to get him rams he's got
leverage over the rams they gave up two
ones and a four to get jalen ramsey and
i remember dion sanders who's connected
to ramsey because they're both florida
state guys dion sanders in the immediate
aftermath of that trade saying ramsay
may not be with the rams for all that
long now look they can franchise tag him
for a couple of years before it becomes
too expensive to keep him but the
question is do you want a guy who
doesn't want to be there if he decides
after this year or during this year i
want out see that's the risk you take
when you trade for a guy who was willing
to draw that line in the sand with a
team and say i want out you may be that
next team where he plays that i want out
card and what are you gonna do you ain't
gonna get two ones and a four for him
this time that's for damn sure so look i
the rams i'll tell you what
the the rams have been very aggressive
but yeah there's been some questionable
moves they've made some mistakes the
jared goff contract the ramsay trade
without a contract the todd gurley
contract and and that team could be
starting to go in the other direction
all right this is the last time i have
to deal with the radio clock forcing me
to take a break before i'd like to
take a break i finished this tuesday
edition of pft live right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports